hong kong wants to show
that life here will soon be back to
normal
and on a day like this that's easy to
imagine
as hundreds of people took part in one
of the territories biggest annual
festivals
the dragon boat race a scene that to
some
offers proof hong kong's freedoms remain
intact but it's also a place where it
seems
social distancing rules are selectively
enforced
it's rare that this event can happen
during the covet 19 pandemic
our team is fully vaccinated and we have
full confidence in the abilities of the
organizers to maintain safety protocols
i'm not that surprised but
the fact that no one social this is
saying it's a bit scary as well
just over a week ago the government
banned another popular annual event
the june the fourth vigil that
commemorates those killed by chinese
troops
in beijing's tiananmen square 32 years
ago
the authorities said the order was
justified on public health grounds
it didn't stop small acts of defiance
strict health regulations are not the
only controls people are dealing with
it's almost a year since china's leaders
imposed a draconian security law
a response to months of often violent
anti-government protests here
under that law more than a hundred
activists have been arrested
with most denied bail hong kong people
are now hesitant to protest and to get
vaccinated
there's been a sluggish response to the
inoculation
campaign as only around twenty percent
of the population
have received a single dose of the
covid19 vaccine
after some prodding by the government
corporate hong kong
is now dangling incentives to try to
persuade people
to get inoculated offering prizes that
include
an apartment in this complex valued at
more than a million and a half dollars
the slow pickup blamed on a lack of
trust in the government
and concerns over vaccine safety
but there's also another incentive for
people to get inoculated
a new outbreak of covert 19 in the
neighboring chinese province
of guangdong adrian brown al jazeera
hong kong